Wooow
That actually have worked. What's up guys welcome back to the shop. for another pyro project.
For this video I went down to the dollar store
And I clean them out of these little tiny smoke balls they come out around this time of year
And I actually counted all these we have 75 pack of 6 balls each. That's a total of 450
mini Smoke bombs that we can consoladate into 4  giant smoke bombs and thats the purpose of this project today
Here's the basic idea. I went and picked up four different cups here because we have four different colors
We've got yellow white blue and purple
Now if you take one of these little smoke bombs and look inside
We're going to find is there's a layer of paper on the top once you pull that apart you can see there's a seam line
That connects two halves of a cardboard sphere if you give it a little pop with your thumb
You can split the whole thing open and find a little smoke pellet. That's inside
So our job at this point is to simply crack all
450 smoke bombs open pull the pellets out and group them by their respective colors all right cool. Let's get cracking
Instrumental Music
There we go. There's the last package. They're all out it would be fun almost to light this off
We've got a mountain of smoke bomb and that by itself could be a pretty epic time but in the interest of saving space
We're in the cracking things down to extract all those pellets and organize them into their respective colors
Instrumental Music
All right here. We are guys we have shelled
450 smoke bombs and put them into the different containers one thing that I notice is they're really really heavy on the white
Next up is blue then we have yellow then we have purple. What was really interesting about this patch
I don't know where these came from we ended up with two green totally random. So now that we've got these things full
I'm really tempted just to go outside and light them off the one question
I have is should we wrap them up in aluminum
Foil to make them jet out one hole or should we just let the whole thing burned and see how that reacts
Now these are paper cups so I think at least what I'm going to do is put a couple of wraps of aluminum foil around
The side help reinforce them then let's go outside
Let's light the yellow one off first and depending on how it reacts we can make a few adjustments in there
Instrumental Music
All right, we've got the aluminum Foil on our cup so it's time to head outside and try two different experiments the first one
We're going to light off one of these smoke bombs as is and see how it performs
Then we're going to light up one of our souped-up versions and see how they compare
So we got four of the regular dollar-store smoke bombs. We're going to light them up and see how they react here we go
Here we go
Instrumental Music
Yeah, so that was kind of pathetic
Yeah, that's kind of anticlimactic, but pretty much what you expect from Dollar store smoke bombs
They only burn for about five seconds
And they're so light and flimsy they roll around the wind
So let's see how they compare to our homemade version where we've got a hundred of them in a cup
Now the question really is when we light one of these off is it going to ignite the whole batch?
Or is it just going to go out by itself and fizzle down and die
I guess there's really only one way to find out so we're going ahead and light up now all right
Let's play it up moment of truth
Whoa, that's hot thank it's hot in a hurry
new doggy
Wow, wow wow?
okay, so
Look down here. You can see all the charred remnants of what should have been smoked
And it does totally charred went off all at once now 300 - the cup lit on fire - good thing
We put the aluminum foil around and that helped give it some integrity well, the one thing I noticed there was no
Yellow smoke it just went up in this huge cloud big puff of like
I don't even know what a lot of flames, and then just drifted away
Instrumental Music
Lighting up remember that's a lot of fire. What surprised me about that reaction
Is there really wasn't much smoke at all it just kind of went up in flames
So where did all the coloring go I see traces of it on the brick and on the road itself?
But there was a lot of coloring in there, and now it's completely gone. It's very odd
My guess is the reaction was too hot and everything just burned up
So there was no chance to the smoke to just gently walked away
I'm not very confident these other ones are going to work for we're going to light them off
But just to be sure I think the next one we're going to dump out in a pile there spread a little more evenly
Next up, we got the purple all right here. We go if this works any better
I'm going to start at the side to see if we get a slower burn and keep that makes a difference
Instrumental Music
Wow that gets hot in a hurry
interesting interesting
This is interesting okay. Let's talk about this, so that's our second batch
We lit it off and ignite so quickly the only smoke that I see is like a grayish smoke that evaporates
I don't see any color whatsoever and all the dye is just left over here is like charred remnants
That's really pretty see that's what we were expecting something of that nature so what I'm noticing here guys
I'm seeing a pattern here that if this burns, too hot
And I think collectively all of these are too hot then instead of releasing the dye it scorches it
And it doesn't release any color at all so we pretty much know what to expect at this point
But just for fun to wrap this whole thing in aluminum
Foil at the risk of it exploding just to see how it reacts in the confined environment
All right here. We go big one
is Lit
whoa
We did
Look up there. We got a cloud of smoke trailing away
I thought I saw a little bit of color out of there not very much though
That was interesting so it actually blew a hole through the top of the aluminum foil here
There's still little bits of random pieces going up there and a lot of fire. I don't actually
Know what that is. That's the cup on the inside. That's burning
But that just exploded out the top it through
if you look at this loma on that you can actually see the fuses you can see like bits of
Smoke bomb flying out the top everywhere is a very dramatic reaction
It's kind of hard to tell if this worked or not because these were actually the white smoke bombs
They did definitely see a big cloud of white go off. I can't really tell if this worked or not so just for fun
We're going to wrap up the last one. This is a full cup of blue and see what it does
There's probably about 125 blue smoke bombs in here however. I'm not very optimistic. It's going to work
I think it's just going to explode and is going to release black and white smoke
However, you never know if you try. So here we go. Let's do it once it's lit. There's no turning back
Oh, nice. I got a little bit of blue there, whoa. Oh
that
That actually half worked
I mean for about a foot and a half off of that thing I can actually see
Thick blue smoke it actually went very very quickly like four or five seconds
it was completely gone and it spit out all this blue dye all over the road and then it kind of went up into a
Whitish smoke which is actually insane
Very dramatic reaction it spit a blue dye everywhere
It's all over the sidewalk all over the road it's going to be a little bit of a mess to clean up, but that was pretty cool
Don't know if it's worth spending the money to make a giant smoke bomb
But that was a pretty cool reaction so thinking back on the experiments that we just tried here today
We really tried five different experiment
We took smoke bombs from the dollar store and lit them off and found they burn between three to six seconds with a very wimpy
plume of smoke
So we shelled those smoke bombs suck all the yellow ones in the container and list them off all at once what we found was
a little bit unexpected
Rather than a giant cloud of yellow smoke there was absolutely no colored smoke at all at least assuming that white smoke doesn't really count
What I think happened instead was so much heat was released that it charged the dye and prevent any colored smoke from being released at
All so for our second experiment
we spread all the purple smoke bombs out on a couple of bricks to see if by increasing the surface area would help slow the
Burn and the Idea might have worked but they were still in such close proximity
That the whole thing went up in a ball of fire with no visible color for the third experiment
We tried wrapping a cup full of white smoke bomb in aluminum
Foil a few times to see how they would burn confined and when we lit them off
We did actually see a big cloud of white smoke take off now since it was white smoke bombs
We couldn't tell whether or not it had anything to do with the process so for our fourth experiment
We wrapped the blue ones up in a similar manner there still was an enormous amount of pressure that built up and exploded
But what surprised me was we actually saw an explosion of color as well at least for the first foot to foot and a half
Above the container
So there you have it guys if you ever had a burning desire to know what would happen if you took hundreds of smoke bombs
And burn them all together now you know thanks for joining us for this experiment
I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you them
Yeah, these aren't insulated gloves. These are wrong gloves for the job. Yeah, I play with fire. You expect to get burned Random happen
Hey guys, there is an event called CVx live that. I'm going to be at august 3rd through 5th stage presentations meet and greets
There's even a special superfan experience where we can hang out one-on-one
So click the link in the description and I'll be looking for you at the PDF live